What happened with me with this film,
so I accepted the film and I was really
excited to,
to take this and I love the idea and I
was reading it and I've gotten probably
two weeks into my preparation for the
film and my father was diagnosed with
cancer and I was like,
you know,
first it,
it stunned me and then it was the
magical work of the universe.
I could not believe that this was the
film I was working on and I was,
you know,
forced to face,
my father is mortality.
So it was,
it was rough for about a week and I got
it together and I decided that we would
use the process of the character who was
suffering a loss.
And I would share my preparation with my
father.
And so we just started talking about
love,
time and death.
And we,
we,
it was some of the most open and
powerful conversations that we,
you know,
we,
we'd ever had.
And um,
they,
they gave him six weeks and he actually,
he lived for four months.
So about three months into the six
weeks,
you know,
I go to see him one day and he said,
man,
this shit is embarrassing.
And I said,
what?
Daddy said,
man,
you tell everybody you will be dead.
Okay.
Six weeks later you still hanging around
ms dot right.
It was so beautiful.
He got,
we got to a place that we were talking
open and,
and comedically yet.
And really I think I was able to embody
the ideas of the loss and also the
redemptive quality of the pain.
You know,
the,
the loss is bound to joy.
Like pain and suffering are bound to
joy.
The,
the,
being able to survive something is
actually a big part of being able to
find that next wave of joy.
You appreciate the smaller things,
right?
Like it was so magnificent for me.
Um,
you know,
my,
my father died on a,
on November seventh,
um,
but it was so powerful for me to be
cleansed of box office.
Like I don't need the box office to be
huge on this film.
I don't need to win any awards,
you know,
I don't care.
It was the film that I worked on it,
I was actually able to comfortably and
beautifully say goodbye to my father and
I hope that this film embodies a bit of
that.
So other people who are experiencing
things like that,
we'll be able to use it in that,
in that way and it can potentially be
helpful and help someone else.
So it was,
it was powerful to be cleansed of the
foolishness of the game of numbers and
awards and all of that type of stuff to
actually be able to be able to create a
piece of art that legitimately I just
want people to see and hope it can be
helpful and transformative in their
lives.
You're talking about perspective
perspective?
Absolutely.
Yes.
How much is fair play into preventing us
from grasping perspective though?
Oh,
no,
fears.
Everything.
Yeah.
Like if,
if there's,
if there was one,
a concept that I would
suggest to people to take a daily
confrontation with his fear.
Um,
the,
the problem with fear is that it lies,
right?
So fear tells you,
hey,
you know,
if,
if you say that to that girl,
she's going to know he has you,
you know,
and she'll never really be attracted to
you if she knows how much you attracted
to her.
Don't say that.
No.
How we get her is when she walks by.
Ignore her.
You know,
it's like,
fear tells you dumb shit like that,
you know.
So for me,
the,
the daily confrontation,
um,
we're with fear has become a real
practice for me since about three,
three years ago,
um,
I went,
uh,
I went skydiving in Dubai,
right as skydiving,
skydiving.
Really interesting.
Confront with fear,
right?
So I gotta I gotta stand up.
All right,
so,
so all your friends,
what happens?
You go out how you.
Oh,
sorry,
dropped my thing.
So what happens is you go out the night
before and you,
you know,
you take a drink with your friends and
somebody says,
yeah,
we should go skydiving tomorrow.
And you go,
yeah,
we'll go skydiving.
Well,
yes.
Everybody goes,
yeah,
right.
And you go home and you're by yourself.
You're like,
right.
well,
yeah,
I mean they,
they was drunk too,
right?
So,
so maybe,
maybe they not,
maybe,
maybe.
I mean we don't have to go,
we don't have to do it.
So then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just keep,
you're terrified.
You keep imagining over and over again
jumping out of an airplane and you can't
figure out why you would do that.
Right.
And you're laying there and you have the
worst night's sleep of your life,
but you still have to hope that your
friends were drunk.
Right?
So you wake up the next day and you go
down and you said where you were going
to meet and everybody's there.
You're like,
ah,
shit.
Alright,
alright,
cool.
Cool,
cool,
cool.
Right.
So you get in a van and you don't know
that your friends had the same night
that you had.
Cause they're pretending like they
didn't.
They were like,
yeah man,
my uncle's a navy seal and you know,
it's going to be great.
I'm looking forward to this.
And you're like,
oh my God,
Oh my God.
And your stomach is terrible.
You can't eat.
And everything,
but you don't want to be the only punk
who doesn't jump out of this airplane.
So you get there and then you have the
safety brief and you're standing there
and the guys will tell you what the
chute doesn't open.
What's going to happen is you're doing,
you will help with while working out
the shoe.
The shoe wouldn't open,
right?
So you do a thing and what you do is
your first jump.
You're attached to a guy who,
you know,
he's going to walk you out.
So you go and you get there and there's
an airplane and nobody's stopping.
Everybody's still going.
So you get onto the airplane and you're
sitting there and,
and you know it's extra because you sit
in on some dude's lap,
some stranger,
you sit on his lap and it's,
you know,
you're trying to make small talk.
Yeah man.
So you deal,
you'd be,
you'd be jumping with people all the
time,
Huh?
Right.
You know,
so,
and then you just want to make sure you
got,
you've got kids,
right?
You got people you need to see.
Just want to make sure he series right.
So you get in there,
so everything's normal.
So you fly and you go up,
you go up and you go up and you go up to
14,000 feet and you notice there's a,
a light is red and it's yellow and
green,
right?
So right now the light's red.
So then you start thinking at some point
the light's going to go green if you
don't know what's going to happen,
right?
And you wait and it goes yellow and the
light goes green and somebody opens the
door.
And in that moment you realize you've
never been in a freaking airplane with
the door open,
right?
Right.
Terror.
Oh,
sorry,
I'm speeding.
Oh,
sorry,
go.
Terror,
terror,
terror.
Right?
So you go and then you know,
if you're,
if you were smart,
you sat in the back so you don't go
first,
right?
And then people start going out of the
airplane and you go and the guy walks
you up to the end of the thing and
you're standing and your toes are on the
edge and you're looking out down to
death.
And they say,
Oh,
I'm three.
And they say one,
two,
and he pushes you on to,
because people grab one three,
right?
And you go
and you fall out of the airplane and in
one second you realize that it's the
most blissful experience of your life,
your flying right?
It doesn't feel like falling,
right?
It's like you actually are Kinda held a
little bit by the wind and then you
start and you start falling,
you fallen,
and you.
There's zero fear.
You realize that the point of maximum
danger is the point of minimum fear.
It's Boulez,
it's bliss and you're flying,
right?
Or you're doing it.
And then 20 seconds,
25 seconds,
40 seconds,
and you have enough time to just kind of
be like,
oh shit.
That's that building.
I sound like.
Right,
right.
You start doing all of that.
And the lesson for me was,
why were you scared in your bed the
night before?
Why did you,
what do you need that fear for?
Just don't go.
Why are you scared in your bed?
Sixteen hours before you jump.
Why are you scared in the car?
Why could you not enjoy breakfast with
what,
what?
What did you need to fear is fear of
You're nowhere even near the airplane.
Everything up to the stepping out.
There's actually no reason to be scared.
It only just ruins your day,
your,
you don't have to jump.
And then in that moment,
all of a sudden where you should be
terrified is the most blissful
experience of your life.
And God placed the best things in life
on the other side of terror,
on the other side of your maximum fear.
All of them.
The best things in life.
So that was that.
Sorry.
Was that?
Yeah,
that was,
that was my experience with,
uh,
with sky diving and fear and practically
speaking,
but I didn't like that take.
I'm going to do it again.
Back to this.
I can sell that better.
I can sell it back.
When you decide to do something like
that,
like how does it work practically?
Do you call your wife and be like,
I might be dead tomorrow right now,
but that's just the promise.
I made a drug promise you here.
How about this?
So I jumped.
I had such a mystical,
powerful spiritual experience.
I flew home and got my sons and I went
back and 10 days later my son's jumped
right now.
That was a little different.
I want to say it.
It makes me stand out because I'm
scared.
I'm scared
it was one.
So Jayden went first,
right?
Jaiden wants to do everything first,
so I'm sitting there and I'm like,
yeah,
my sons are going to have this crazy
experience.
And then Jaden went out of the airplane
that was like,
Hey,
no.
My oldest son Trey goes up and he goes
out of the airplane and I was like,
this could potentially be the worst.
I have African American parenting in
history.
It was like both my sons just fell out
of an airplane.
Right?
Because I told them to.
But again,
the fear again,
I was like,
oh my God.
So I told the dude,
I was like,
listen,
I want to see them go out,
but I also want to see them land.
And he's like,
no,
it's cool.
So this time we went out and we did the
straight bullet and I just went straight
down,
pass them.
Right.
It was
good.
Right?
Did the bullish straight past,
pulled his shoot late,
sorry,
pull the shoot late,
landed and then videoed them coming
down.
But it was like they had the same thing,
the same experience with the fear,
but that I'm telling you,
the confrontation with fear is an
absolute,
a magical way of facing the things we
have to do in this life,
you know,
forget security live for.
No.
You say you learned that three years
ago.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Um,
what about the small things that we get
a freedom of?
Right.
So you are the funny guy.
You come along and everybody expects to
be entertained in some muscle.
Are you ever afraid that
you're like,
you know what,
today I'm really not feeling Jazzy Jeff.
I got to just,
I don't want to be that guy today.
So this whole movie,
that guy,
right?
Yeah.
Do you have fear of that?
Of like disappointing people because
like,
you're supposed to be funny and cool.
Yeah.
You know,
the thing that,
that's been one of the,
the major conference for me and my life
over the past three or four years,
like,
um,
there's a,
there's a will smith is an idea,
right?
So there's parts of that that's me,
but that character from the fresh prince
of Bel Air was who I was 26,
six years ago
this month.
He's talking about evolve,
but that,
that's the thing to be able to,
um,
to boldly be able to move and grow and
create and hope that the things that
I'm,
you know,
able to deliver at this point.
You know,
I was,
I was 20 during the fresh prince,
you know,
so I'm,
I'm a 48 now,
so it's a,
it's a,
it's a really different time in my life.
Yeah.
That got less of a chair.
Like,
tell us what that's like.
Um,
but yeah,
you know,
you have a fear of being completely who
you are because it may disappoint some
people just want to see that 28
year olds.
No,
I definitely,
um,
have difficulty with that.
You know,
there's a certain,
you know,
when you,
when you've created things that are so
iconic,
it becomes healing for people.
Nostalgia as healing,
you know,
to the fresh prince theme is healing to
hear that,
you know,
it just hearkens back to a time and a
feeling and an energy,
you know,
that is,
um,
a,
a beautiful way to help relieve,
uh,
some,
some little touch of suffering,
you know,
so when people see me or the fresh
prince and even during that time,
the movies that I made while I was
making the fresh prince.
So it was the fresh prince during the
winter and then the summers were bad
boys
pendants,
you know,
so it was like,
it really captured a time.
Um,
so it,
it,
it's,
it's very difficult.
I wouldn't have it any other way.
I love being able to make people smile
and sheer,
you know,
over that.
But I also am going to boldly go to new
creation.
Um,
you know,
even something,
something like the decision,
um,
you know,
I had the two screenplays in front of me
for the independent state two and for
suicide squad.
So I had to choose between the two of
those and even the choice of going to
suicide squad,
know nothing about the qualities of the
movies,
but the choice of trying to go forward
versus clinging and climbing backwards,
you know,
so I,
I do want to aggressively go forward and
do new things and create and hopefully,
uh,
be able to stumble upon a new hay day.
Amazing.
Now you have an incredible cast.
Oh God,
yes.
Yeah.
How does that happen to like how does so
many big stars this and then how does
that work between you?
You know,
it's the,
the ideas,
the screenplay.
Allan Loeb,
the screenwriter,
he just wrote a brilliant screenplay.
Everyone related to the ideas of love,
time and death as a powerful tools to
try to put your life back on track.
So everyone related to the journey,
but it's,
I mean,
I mean look at that group,
that's like a,
it was like a superhero movie,
but did your,
did your father get to see any of it?
No.
He came to set a once but he didn't,
he didn't get to see the film.
And y'all are close that we were very
close.
Yeah.
My,
my father,
um,
I uh,
put my life together and I look at my
father and my mother and grandmother
were the most influential people in my,
my life and in my mind when I draw it,
always draw a triangle.
And My,
my father was the base.
Uh,
my mother was the left side and my,
my grandmother was the right side and I
always put discipline as the bottom.
My father hard work,
discipline.
Endurance was really the foundation of
creating my life.
And My mother was education and my
grandmother was loved.
So you know,
the combination of that discipline,
education and love was a,
I'm really grateful for you
sharing with us that part of you and
also the struggle with his death.
Because the other thing is that we live
in a time where people show these
curated sides of them because I think of
the same fair,
right?
You just want to be this piece and all
the rest of it.
Yeah.
It's a struggle,
but he wants to hear all of that.
You know,
it's facebook.
Come on,
let's have fun,
Dude.
It's a bummer.
Your Dad's gone.
No,
no,
no.
Come on.
No,
no.
You know,
for me is laughing is the elixir and
that was another thing that my father
taught me.
He was,
he was joking all the way up to the end,
like laughing.
You have to be able to laugh at
everything.
And for me the beautiful part is that
that's my natural.
I'm a color on the spectrum.
I naturally go to comedy,
you know,
and when,
when,
when I'm looking at something,
I'm always trying to find why that's
funny and it's been really,
really helpful in,
in this experience and you know,
even just a this point in my life,
keep remember to laugh,
remember to laugh and,
and spend time with people that make you
laugh.
Like that is hugely important.
Laugh.
Connect.
Yes,
absolutely.
It was a good messages.
Yeah.
I love this,
this idea,
you know,
it's,
um,
you know,
a guy tried to put his,
put his life back together and he just
gets furious and rants and writes
letters to love,
time and depth.
And then love time and depth.
Respond,
you know,
so it's,
it's,
you know,
a really that beautiful Christmas flavor
was know,
just a little touch outside of reality,
you know,
so you get to,
you get to deal with real subjects and
real topics and real loss,
but because it touches just that New
York Christmas,
just a little bit outside of the,
you know,
how excruciating it would be if you
dealt with it,
you know,
straight,
hard rated our loss,
you know.
So I,
I just love going into that realm of,
uh,
of um,
the mystical to be able to take a good
look at,
at,
you know,
real human issues.
So you're talking about real.
I felt it was the most related.
You be really
like I felt there was no filter there
and I wondered for somebody who could
choose to do anything.
Was that something special that drove
you to this?
You know,
when I,
when I first read it,
you know,
when I,
when I first read it,
every once in a while you,
you know,
you read a screenplay and the,
the most important thing in a movie,
I guess the,
you know,
the,
the two most important things that I
look for is one is the universally
relatable concept,
right?
So just at its core,
when you first say it,
when you say one line about it,
can you connect to people you know,
and what,
you know,
one of the,
one of the best ones I've ever had with
something with like I am legend,
the last man on earth.
Yeah.
Security
is actually right here,
you know,
but it's like when you,
when you just have that one thing,
you know,
and with this it was a,
it was a little bit heavier,
but it was a guy trying to put his life
back together after an extreme loss.
Right.
So people can relate to that.
That's a,
that's an extremely relatable idea.
And then I flipped to the last 10 pages
and the ending,
it's like,
you know,
this is a movie that has lots of twists
and turns,
but then even within the last 10 pages,
there's still another surprise when you
can send people out of the,
out of a movie theater with another
surprise.
You know,
and you know,
historically there's been times I've
sent people out of the movie theater and
the surprise in the last 10 minutes is
that the movie wasn't good,
right?
So you just want to avoid that surprise.
You want to avoid that one.
Uh,
you know,
but with this one is,
it has such an interesting turn in,
in the end of it.
And it was,
it was,
um,
you know,
one of the most fun screenplays I've
ever read.
Why are you doing movies at all?
Still?
Like,
you're rich.
You could,
as we say,
cock up your foot back,
cock up my foot and rock back,
getting you out of bed to still go and
do this thing.
Uh,
I,
um,
I enjoy
connecting with people and ideas.
And you know,
it,
it's,
I have a mission statement.
So every year,
for probably the past 10 years I've
worked out a mission statement for
myself and for the last few few years
the mission statement has stayed the
same and it,
you know,
it's been improved lives,
right?
So when,
when I go into something,
I'm looking for how the quality of this
piece could potentially improve lives,
but it's all along the way.
It's when you make the movie and how
you're interacting with people in the
process and you know,
at the,
the,
the concept of lives runs through the
center of everything I do.
And then I realized that the,
the,
the way to improve lives is to
continually improve yourself.
Right?
So with that,
every,
every morning when I,
when I get out of the bed,
you know,
I,
I haven't fixed everything in the world
yet.
So there's always something to do.
And in this film I read an interesting
quote for the,
uh,
sit hearth,
a Gotama,
the Buddha.
He said,
um,
that,
good people have to get out of the bed
every day and try to empty the ocean
with a ladle.
Right?
And I thought that was a new,
that was profound.
And I paused for a second and I said,
all right,
what the hell is a ladle?
Right,
right.
So then,
you know,
I just,
I touched it on my ipad is later.
Oh,
it's like a big spoon,
spoon,
a soup spoon.
And I was like,
why you assume smell.
So try to empty the ocean with a soup
spoon,
you know,
as the,
the mentality of how you,
you wake up everyday to try to do good
in the world.
So for me,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm really driven by continually trying
to,
um,
elevate my,
elevate my mind and elevate my spirit
and care for my body and to be able to
love as many people as effectively as,
as possible with this mystery of life
that I've been given.